[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
June 15th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
half of workers surveyed in a new Gallup
poll say they're not engaged on the job
a lot of them are unhappy and resentful
that their needs aren't being met Wall
Street Journal workplace reporter
Lindsay Ellis joins us to go deeper to
understand why workers sentiment has
gone South so Lindsay first of all how
is worker engagement defined and why is
it important so Employee Engagement is a
measure of how enthusiastic and involved
you are at work and it's an important
thing to measure because it tends to
correlate with a few things that
employers really care about how
productive you are and how loyal you are
to the company or organization you know
it's also important because it gives
some signal as to how happy someone
might be at work you know whether the
day-to-day is enjoyable or if it feels
like you're sort of trudging uphill you
know it wasn't that long ago you were
with us talking about quiet quitting
where workers were putting in minimal
effort to get by how is what's going on
now different so just as last year
Gallup says that about half of U.S
workers are not engaged at work so
similar to quiet quitting you know
people putting in minimal effort day to
day to do their jobs and not go above
and beyond what's different now is that
there's a growing share of the workforce
that is disengaged that group is more
resentful that their needs aren't being
met and in some cases these workers are
disgruntled over low pay and long hours
or maybe they've lost trust in their
employers and so that proportion of the
workforce is increasing as the sort of
not engaged quiet quitting shares is
holding steady at about 50 percent but
as recently as 2020 the Gallup poll
showed that worker engagement levels had
hit their highest levels ever what
pushed those levels so high in 2020 some
of the engagement was really driven by
companies early responses to the
pandemic there were tons of town halls
and meetings early on in which
Executives and managers were really
overly communicating with their workers
and that kept relationships strong kept
people you know on similar pages and
workers said that they were more engaged
at that point but the poll says Employee
Engagement has declined for two straight
years what are workers saying about that
so some workers are saying that they are
less connected to their offices and
workplaces which they attribute in part
to remote workers also say that they
would change key aspects of their jobs
to to make things better perhaps
unsurprisingly they want higher salaries
less over time and clearer goals from
their managers they also are saying that
they want more autonomy at work and so
those are kind of key areas that workers
see as areas for improvement in their
day-to-day on the job but didn't we just
go through a big reset the great
resignation where millions of people
switch jobs to gain more flexibility and
more pay which in turn raise the pay for
many people who didn't leave their jobs
yes and you know a separate survey from
the conference board found that among
the nation's happiest workers are those
who did exactly that you know
voluntarily switched jobs over the
pandemic and for those individuals their
pay likely increased and they also may
have a role that is a better fit which
can drive up their happiness for those
job switchers you know you mentioned
efforts to bring people back into the
office and that was really meant to
increase Employee Engagement has that
backfired it's a great question so
Gallup and McKenzie both say that a few
days a week in the office can be really
helpful to to get people on the same
page Gallup points to improvements in
problem solving and collaboration as two
of the reasons for that but it is a type
of policy that can really irritate
workers and we've seen at a number of
companies in recent weeks employees are
pushing back against either stricter
return to work policies or stricter
enforcement of return to work policies
the sort of flip side of that coin is
that some workers who have joined their
companies in recent years may not feel
as connected to them if they've been
working entirely remotely you know I
talked to one person who recently left
his job but when he was at the position
he only met his co-workers a handful of
times and he said while in past
positions I've had good friends at the
office I don't really feel like I'm
leaving with as tight of relationships
and we which he attributed to this
remote work and those relationships are
definitely a key factor in engagement so
I think all of these issues with the
office it's kind of an interesting
question because you've seen workers
really push back against highly enforced
policies but not having any face-to-face
time According to some firms does create
some distance between a worker and their
employer so how is this affecting their
relationship with managers and
Executives so the relationship between
someone and their manager is actually
one of the most important aspects of
Engagement According to Jim harder who
was the lead author of this Gallup
report even more than where people work
that relationship has huge implications
for an individual's engagement level and
harder recommended that managers should
meet with their team members one-on-one
at least once a week to develop that
relationship and also to kind of make
clearer what one's expectations are and
setting those expectations and being
really clear about that I think is also
something that workers really appreciate
that's Wall Street Journal reporter
Lindsay Ellis and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign